this is the theme the teacher this is
the days is the D smell a hundred la
Salaam alaikum peace be with you welcome
to the D show special guest this is
unscripted unrehearsed this is something
really an amazing show that's coming up
with my friend my new friend here Frank
whole is how are you free good i had no
idea you're going to be here in chicago
on the Dean shot today did you not any
idea at all no but life is a challenge
it's a test as we come to know the
crater is telling us that he's created
life and death to test which of us are
best indeed we know as those who are
submitted to the will of God as Muslims
that life is a test there's going to be
many challenges and obstacles but we
have to struggle to be good to do good
to be on the way that's pleasing to the
crater before we meet him and we had an
incredible situation will let you into
my life a little bit now and see some of
the tests that we're going through we
have one situation here that we're
dealing with and we want people to
benefit so you tomorrow can benefit from
this story and avoid something like this
happening to you so how about I start
off for it sells that yes okay here's
how it goes his how we met and we'll
bring you up to speed you know I was
driving a car i purchased a two thousand
four four and i had it for me about a
couple years and i decided to sell it
had about 100 87,000 miles so I had my
friend Omar cuz you know I'm very busy I
don't have time to be you know going on
craigslist and on the other advert sites
and and answering the calls and so I I
had somebody Omar friend of mine who
works for Toyota list the car and he was
the one that was taking care of all
these things for me he gives me a con
says we got a buyer come on down and my
job is just to sign the title and count
the cash right so what happens is we end
up selling the car I saw the car and
then some time labor later I get a call
while email from my friend Frank here
Frank who's also a kettlebell instructor
for people they know don't know what
that is
Bell right yes haha so come to know that
the guy who I sold the car to he went
and did what's called a title jump is
that right I just learned this this
fancy word title junk he altered the
title went and sold it to Frank and will
continue from there what happened well
he had sold it to me saying it had
77,000 miles on it so I of course took a
four test drive and it was in great
shape he cleaned it up very well it
looked like it was a car that would had
that many miles on it so he wrote down
077 on the title and that kind of was a
little bit of a flag but I was excited
to get this vehicle because it was a
very good price for such a low mile and
afterwards after the excitement the next
morning I woke up and thought that there
were some odd things about his behavior
so I did a carfax report on it and found
out that indeed it was I was misled and
it had over a hundred and seventy seven
thousand miles on it at that time under
87,000 to be specific right based on
what your document showed me it had a
hundred the carfax actually showed what
was it it showed the last reported was
169 which was on the top of your title
but it had actually according to Eddie
and and truthfully it had 187,000 miles
on it and it was sold to me as if it had
77 for obviously a lot more cash so the
people are like well why didn't you look
at the odometer what I mean doesn't the
odometer say the actual mileage the
odometer did say 77,000 on it so it was
either it was most likely modified or
replaced or something so that was
tampered with it actually shows what is
the show 77,000 on it right now and now
they can see the title you can see what
what when I saw the the car to the
person that we made it what what a
person should do is make the copy of the
title right and then the bill of sale
and then you see on there that it said
you know the hundred what 60 well when I
got it when I sold it when when he got
it he had wrote when he
old it he had written in 187 thousand
that was a race when I had to his no
mileage written down on that he had
taken at his title and he raised values
from it and his own signature to make it
look as though he was Eddie selling it
to me so what he actually tell you now
that now were you concerned to say this
doesn't match up you know why are you
did you ever think that you're not the
actual owner what he tell you to make
you believe now that this deal is legit
he had he had said that he was selling
this for a friend so he was almost
reiterating what Eddie's experience with
Omar was saying he was doing it for a
friend and that's how he made and he had
two children in the car so I'm thinking
that it's it's you know he's a family
man and he's being honest and that is
truthful so but in fact as it turns out
he had actually altered the odometer as
well as at his title so that's how we
came into contact because I thought
because coincidentally the guy who
bought the car for me he put down that
his name was Frank Costello right
correct so then when I got message at
email from you to my business because
I'm not a hard person to track down
right right you even got to watch some
of the Dean Shiels didn't you I actually
did I did I did watch a bit of that and
you know who my father was his history
you know all about us right so it was
odd that this that I didn't think it was
Eddie that sold it to me at that point
and Plus after seeing the photos and
like I knew it wasn't the same person so
I knew something was definitely at this
point wrong and that's when I actually
contacted Eddie and went down to Chicago
to meet him in person and and to find
out that you know that he really is who
he said he is and his upstanding guy
well Frank Costello whoever his name is
his legitimate he didn't think he'd be
on the Dean show too because we got some
surveillance footage don't we yes we do
so we we got his picture his name I've
got phone numbers so we've got a lot to
go on hopefully when we go to the
authorities we can we can catch him to
prevent us in the future so now you
contacted place of business I thought I
was calling that
I back I thought well maybe he's asking
me something out the car you wanted to
talk to me so then I called that number
that he left for me and the guy was like
who is this basically because I didn't
email you back I called the number i
thought i was calling the guy that I saw
the car too so here we are so then I
call back and the guys like well I don't
know what you're talking about he said
this is a new number so I guess the
number got like he gave me a fake number
so then I email you ask for your number
I call you and then what were you asking
me I actually called you and I'm like
you're talking about something and I'm
like confused what is this I was trying
to explain that this guy who called
himself Anthony that sold me it I was
telling Eddie that he yeah this guy
Anthony that you had sell your car to me
had the wrong mileage on there and and
and that he's like I don't understand
what you're talking about who's this
anthony guy so i sold it to Frank a
different Frank so so we knew something
was up and we arranged to meet here at
Gracie Barra so now obviously you know
we this is something that you know no
one likes to have themselves ripped off
because obviously you know this is
something that is sad that it happens
that we have criminals out there so we
wanted I was thinking it's good that we
got to meet we want to look at there's
got to be some greater good that's going
to come from it and we as Muslims we're
taught because islam teaches us to go
ahead and help others so it's because of
Islam that we try to do our best to help
our brothers in humanity because you
know we have empathy and for for
everybody that's out there we would
never want something like this to happen
to us so the people who are watching
this now hopefully they can learn a
lesson from this situation hopefully now
this will be on many of the major
networks on there we're on five
satellite channels here the show is
aired in Chicago local TV maybe some CNN
Fox will pick this up put his name out
there we don't know but then other
people now how can they people because
people do transactions all the time
honest legit transactions right they
want to sell their car what lesson can
they learn from this I made a lot of
mistakes I did not confirm the person
with an actual driver's license
and I did not look over the title
carefully to see you know if you look
carefully there were some scratches on
it and fold marks that that could have
been a sign those are things initially
and and to go maybe directly to the
currency exchange to transfer to the
title right away those are some mistakes
that I had made that I that I feel you
know bad about because it was not smart
in any way shape or form but and it's
embarrassing to it to an extent but I
want to look past that and I want to
help anybody out in the future so it's
gonna I'm going to pay for this mistake
so hopefully somebody else does not have
to and we were talking about it can
always be worse right we were talking
about that let's say we we might suffer
now maybe to prevent something greater
from happen let's say tomorrow you know
in this whole thing we always because we
always are taught to look at those who
have less a situation can always be
worse obviously we want this person to
be brought to justice and we don't want
this to happen to anybody but somebody
and this whole thing you know maybe your
family could have got hurt maybe down
the line you know hey this can make you
be sharper that tomorrow you know maybe
you're doing a big multi-million dollar
deal and you're not going to ever let
something like this happen again you're
going to be do your more due diligence
right and you know it's all to make the
world a better place to be safer and and
hopefully to make people more aware and
and you know you don't want it can be a
lot worse there could have been physical
harm not just financial my family could
have been involved and and that sort of
thing and we want to avoid that we want
to bring these people to justice that's
that's all I can say is that we do you
know that's why I'm doing this yeah so
next time if you're selling the car what
would you say for the person now that
actually is going to do a transaction go
to the currency exchange maybe what else
can you tell them what are the tips
would you do what would you do
differently I make sure that who you're
who the person selling it to you is the
actual person that matches the title
either with the driver's license or some
other form of identification so that
it's not somebody it may have stolen the
car trying to sell it to you that's one
thing and I think after the transaction
is complete it may be best just to go to
the currency change exchange with the
title to make sure it gets transferred
over and doesn't get modified in the
future to the person that you either
sold it to or well that would be the
case where if you're selling it if I'm I
thought I were going to sell vehicle to
a stranger i'm going to make sure that
that title doesn't be carried on or
modified and then hurt somebody else
those are the main those yeah that was
there the main types of tips I again I
wouldn't he had to make sure you have
the right person you'd said something in
your exchange back with the person tell
us you said something that really you
know we believe that everyone is born in
original goodness that we all have this
innate in each nature to do good right
society might corrupt us our friends
family but everyone has been created
with a clean page and they have this
ambition to do good to be good and to
only worship the creator and not his
creation now when you wrote something in
the text you talked about how can you be
an example for those kids there was kids
in a car your talk about that because
that would touch someone's heart someone
who has any bit of good that would wake
that that goodness I caption sites and I
did I did try to what you said I texted
him saying that because he had basically
said that it was sold as is and he has a
bill of sale therefore he's not going to
deal with me or help me or anything and
I I let's get this rate so now when you
you get the carfax you see that hey this
is not matching up so now you try to you
have some number that he left you so now
you're you're what was the first
interaction with next first exchange
what did you say I was trying to work it
out with him to say this is dishonest
and I felt that I would appeal to him
first before I accuse them of anything
and went to the authorities I figure
maybe I can appeal to the goodness to
have him maybe say I guess you're okay
and I didn't mean to do that and maybe
give me some of the money back I don't
know
his route into his responses basically
he wasn't he didn't want anything to do
with me and then I texted back saying
that I really felt that it was very
dishonest and what example was he
setting to the children that were in the
car with him that you know it I don't
know what he told the children what he
was doing but ultimately it it's a bad
example to these children that what you
can trick somebody out of the money and
that's a good thing so I'm hoping that I
would appeal to him that that it was a
bad example for his children and he's
going to perpetuate this evilness unless
he stops it or and it or get stopped so
you know things have a funny way we
believe you do good you get good what
goes around comes around if you plant
seeds of goodness goodness is going to
sprout if you plant seeds of evil you
will suffer the consequences and
definitely if not in this life in the
next the day of judgment that's what all
the messengers of God taught not only
did they teach we as Muslims believe
that they all brought the same message
worship the Creator Jesus came with that
same message worship the crater not the
creation they came with that good news
meaning if you do good you be do you get
the reward of paradise if you do evil
you live a corrupt like like this person
you're going to be accountable and
Hellfire will be a place so now tell us
for that person that's out there and
like I said funny thing you know he's
watching the TV BAM he sees his picture
on there and you got a chance to address
him what would you say to him I am
disappointed I I don't know why he chose
to do this to somebody like me and it is
not just financial but it seems personal
and I would like to think that he
wouldn't put anybody through this type
of trial and tribulation that he would
you know come clean and change his ways
I I don't have a lot of faith in him
doing that but that's what I wish would
happen so the I i I'm an optimistic
person I think that that the world
should be a good place and that's
probably why I fell prey to him because
I I my idea of how the world should be
would not include people doing these
wrongful things like this but
change change around and do what's right
and don't do this to other people yes
definitely and we're gonna we're going
to go ahead on what's our next place
going to the police station to file
everything we need to do and and
hopefully get past this so we'll keep
you posted lets you know what happened
and the next I got it I got a gift for
you I got some gifts for you here you
can't come on a Dean show and I get a
gift we got some nice books for you
because you know we don't think also
this is coincidence now it's a good
opportunity that we got to meet at least
now right you got to meet a Muslim you
got to learn a little bit about Islam
you got to be on the Dean show viewed
internationally all over the globe you
never thought in a million years this
would be happening huh so hopefully you
can get get a chance to check and read
you to share that with your family some
some some good information there and we
hope that and we know when we put our
trust in the crater everything will turn
out good so we have to be patience there
is a verse in the glorious quran where
God Almighty is saying that all mankind
is in Los except those who believe and
do good deeds and then speak the truth
live the truth call to the truth and our
patient and this is one of those times
where we have to be patient put our
trust in the crater and God willing
everything will turn out and everything
thank God your family is okay you're
okay and we say inshallah God willing
we've got God's help we turn to Him
alone and we ask he'll facilitate a way
of ease for all of us so thank you very
much thank you for being with us and
we're going to go down to the police
station and we'll keep you posted on
what happened we'll be back God one in
peace so I'm
but you figure out that you know man has
have a purpose if you were to take away
mosquitoes from the planet within a few
months everything dies and just took
away what the mosquito in the scale is
in fact that's a fact mosquitoes
mosquitoes but if you take away mankind
nothing happens so this whole ecosystem
this whole wheel and the soul cycle does
it need you so why are you here this is
the things is the danger this is the
thesis Athene Jew
peace be with you we are here with Frank
HOLIS and we just coming out of the
police station Chicago police station
Chicago's finest and we're gonna let
them do their job what happened inside
we're instructed to contact the Illinois
State Police they have a unit that
specializes in this sort of thing so I'm
going to contact them and and go from
there let them tell me what they need
from for me to do it but according to
this police officer in here the you know
his name he seems to think that this is
a closed cut case and it's we should be
helped so the criminals out there be
where they're coming for you Chicago's
finest and thank you again and we'll be
in touch to get an update on what's
going on thank you very much thank you
peace so and thank you for tuning in to
the D show another exciting show you
know what so much crime and so much evil
out there in the world we have to make a
difference the people
you